llegó el momento de conocer que nos trae
nuestra periodista Marta Moya en revista
de prensa mar también bienvenida muy
buenos días Hola Andrés Buenos días
Marta vamos a iniciar nuestra revista de
prensa hoy recordando una efeméride Y es
que los medios reportan que este 11 de
mayo se cumple el primer aniversario de
la muerte de la periodista chirín abule
empecemos por lo que dice el medio al
yacira por ejemplo sí Andrés vamos a
recordar que esta periodista palestino
estadounidense falleció el 11 de mayo de
2022 mientras cubría una redada por
parte de las fuerzas de incursión
israelíes en yin en la discordania
ocupada la periodista murió de un
disparo en la cabeza fue un caso que fue
muy seguido internacionalmente porque
recordemos esas imágenes del funeral de
wacle cuando los israelíes también
atacaron a las personas que portaban el
féretro incluso casi provocando que se
cayera el ataúd No desde entonces ha
habido numerosos numerosas
investigaciones sobre quién fue
realmente
el responsable de la muerte de al
principio Israel y Estados Unidos
dijeron que las investigaciones no eran
concluyentes luego dijeron que
probablemente había sido un militar
israelí pero que no había sido de manera
intencionada la onus y concluyó que fue
un militar israelí quien disparó en la
cabeza a la periodista y bueno al yacira
entre todo este tiempo llevó el caso a
la Corte Penal Internacional Y hoy
cuando se cumple un año de su muerte a
yasira que es el medio en el que trabajó
Serena durante 25 años hace un perfil
cronológico de la periodista cuando
empezó dice este artículo de jazira
apenas había mujeres periodistas
palestinas que cubrieran la información
en la región empezó en 1997 y
textualmente al yasira dice que fue un
Pilar en los hogares de los territorios
palestinos la región en general y para
los árabes y musulmanes en todo el mundo
y que su funeral masivo da muestra
también textualmente de un testimonio de
coraje a plomo y compromiso y contar las
historias que nadie más contó a lo largo
de su trayectoria profesional Mira
estaba lo que registraba el diario al
jazzira o el portal yasira vamos ahora
con lo que dice medios británicos como
the Garden El guardián Andrés destaca
los homenajes y los eventos
conmemorativos que se han venido
desarrollando en la última semana para
honrar la memoria de la periodista
Serena también destaca que los
familiares y los amigos de la víctima
siguen demandando justicia para la
periodista y que se lleve a cabo una
investigación que avanza de manera muy
lenta y no termina de materializarse Por
otra parte este artículo de The Guardian
sostiene que en estos momentos la había
más prometedora de la investigación
parte de Estados Unidos y es que aunque
durante meses se negó a desarrollar y a
llevar a cabo una investigación de
manera independiente a finales del año
pasado en noviembre el congreso presionó
para que el FBI finalmente desarrollará
esta investigación que todavía no
tenemos las conclusiones de la misma y
bien cerramos este tema con lo que dice
el Washington post en Estados Unidos
Pues sí Andrés en la misma línea el
Washington post destacamos un análisis
que hace Miriam berger y que afirma que
ante las múltiples evidencias que hay
contra Israel por la muerte de Estados
Unidos debería liderar y tener una
posición más fuerte en este tema no que
las investigaciones que han liderado
medios como el Washington post o u otros
portales independientes sostienen que no
hubo fuego cruzado sino que fue un
ataque unidireccional de las fuerzas
israelíes incluso contra los periodistas
y que Estados Unidos debería respaldar
la jurisdicción de la Corte Penal
Internacional y que es una mala noticia
que el gobierno de Joe biden no se haya
posicionado más en firme con este tema y
que en paralelo haya seguido manteniendo
estos vínculos con el gobierno de
extrema derecha sostiene este análisis
que lidera
Marta vamos a cambiar ahora de tema
porque ayer el medio independiente ruso
medusa confirmó con Fuentes del kremlin
que el gobierno ruso está perdiendo la
paciencia con el líder del grupo Wagner
quien ha venido haciendo comentarios
fuera de tono sí Andrés nos referimos a
este medio independiente medusa que está
vetado en la propia Rusia y además
sostiene que Fuentes del kremlin están
perdiendo ya los estribos con goji en el
líder del grupo paramilitar Wagner por
las últimas decisiones que ha tomado no
Y estos vídeos que ha venido publicando
en las últimas semanas diciendo que
necesitaban municiones para hacerse con
la ciudad de bahamut en el don más una
urbe que lleva bajo los combates más de
10 meses y que ayer los ucranianos
decían que los rusos habían retrocedido
dos kilómetros en las últimas jornadas
prigollin amenazó incluso con retirar a
sus hombres de la urbe si el Ministerio
de defensa no dotaba al grupo
paramilitar de las municiones necesaria
Aunque luego rectificaron y luego
volvieron a decir que solo les habían
entregado el 10% de las municiones
acordadas concretamente lo que más ha
molestado al kremlin son estas
declaraciones textuales que hizo prigong
Leo textualmente hay personas que luchan
y hay personas que en algún momento de
sus vidas deben tener reservas Mientras
tanto el abuelo feliz cree que le va
bien Qué debe hacer el país Qué deben
hacer nuestros hijos nuestros nietos el
futuro de Rusia y cómo ganaremos esta
guerra Si de repente y solo estoy
especulando resulta que este abuelo es
un completo imbécil se supone que el
abuelo feliz Es una mención a Vladimir
Putin Aunque luego pri goji lo ha negado
y medusa y otras fuentes dicen que el
kremlin está perdiendo pues ya la
paciencia con este líder y que van a
tener que tomar medidas sino contiene
estas afirmaciones sí que además ya ha
pasado la línea roja y que todo esto
puede formar parte de una frustración de
que pregon se hubiera comprometido
personalmente computing a tomar basmut
en una fecha determinada que
probablemente no se esté dando Y es que
cada vez se agudiza más el tono de
contra el kremlin Marta bien usted nos
trae hoy otro tema del periódico de
España que hace una radiografía sobre
estos grupos paramilitares cada vez más
presentes en conflictos bélicos sí
Andrés Esta es un panorama general de
los grupos de seguridad privada grupos
de mercenarios a sueldo que suelen estar
bajo contratos de los gobiernos y
desempeñan tareas de defensa y de
seguridad un experto consultado por el
medio por el periódico de España
sostiene que el origen de estos grupos
paramilitares estos grupos de seguridad
privados nacieron en los años 90 con la
caída del bloque soviético que en rusa
en Rusia no es solo Wagner sino que hay
otras empresas de mercenarios que están
a cargo de oligarcas y dependen todos
ellos de el gobierno Ruso y que han
participado en conflictos como Libia
Siria Irak o en el naborno caravag sin
embargo sostiene este artículo que el
país que más grupos de mercena tiene es
Estados Unidos con 14 empresas de este
tipo registradas la mayoría de ellas en
el estado de Virginia Y además que la
empresa más famosa es la extinta
blackwater para que se llama Academy y
que participó en conflictos como Irak o
Afganistán así comen otras en otros
conflictos en el continente africano
también destaca que hay otras empresas
de grupos paramilitares radicadas tanto
en Gibraltar que han luchado contra
bocoa aram en Nigeria o otra bastante
particular que se llama delfon y está
radicada en Perú Marte muy rápidamente
vamos a cerrar repasando algunas de las
conclusiones que dejó la entrevista de
ayer del expresidente Donald Trump a la
cadena CNN que por supuesto dejó
titulares polémicos sí Andrés ayer
Donald Trump apareció en CNN New
hampshire donde van a tener lugar las
primeras primarias republicanas el
próximo año y aprovechó para hacer como
siempre campaña electoral el artículo
del usaid today que hemos destacado
empieza así no espere ninguna expresión
de arrepentimiento de en 2024 y
ciertamente ninguna disculpa Donald
Trump dijo entre otras cosas negó por
supuesto el abuso sexual contra la
escritora isin Carroll dijo que ni la
conocía y que era una desquiciada afirmó
que el congreso debería dejar de lado la
deuda y hacer un impago de la deuda se
negó también Trump a responder sobre si
apoyaría una prohibición Federal del
aborto además no condenó la invasión
rusa y dijo que podría llevar la paz a
Ucrania en 24 horas dijo que respetaría
las elecciones de 2024 si son o en las
considera legítimas Y por último que
indultará a aquellos que protagonizaron
el asalto al Capitolio el 6 de enero del
21 Marta Muchas gracias por esta
radiografía sobre lo que dicen los
medios de comunicación Gracias Andrés